the animosity between President Trump
and author Bob Woodward is escalating
tonight just ahead of the release of
Woodward's new book we also have an
update on the search for the author of
that infamous New York Times op-ed piece
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts joins us tonight lots of long
getting jump Brent good evening to you
and here is a headline in the search for
whoever wrote that anonymous op-ed if
the Department of Justice doesn't pick
up the search it's likely that no one
else will sources tell Fox News the
White House has not launched an
investigation of any kind into who
anonymous really is aboard Air Force One
on Friday President Trump ignited a
fierce debate suggesting the Attorney
General should look into who is
responsible for the anonymous op-ed in
The New York Times is there anything
about what was published by the New York
Times investigation if that individual
is in meetings that where national
security is being discussed or other
important topics and they are attempting
to undermine the executive branch that
would certainly be problematic and
something that the Department of Justice
should look into Fox News is told that
while the president was clearly upset by
the op-ed and would like to know who
wrote it there is no list of people
suspected of writing it and no one is
trying to ferret out the author is the
White House actively
trying to find out who this person is or
care we're certainly focused on things
that actually matter it's frankly I
think sad and pathetic that a gutless
anonymous source could receive so much
attention from the media every top-level
administration official has denied
writing the op-ed speaking to Chris
Wallace on Sunday vice-president pence
said he'd be happy to back up his denial
with a polygraph should all top
officials take a lie-detector test and
would you agree to take one I would
agree to take it in a heartbeat but
according to the press secretary that
likely won't be necessary
no lie detectors are being used or
talked about or looked at the White
House and the staff here are focused on
doing our jobs not deal with cowards
that refuse to put their names in an
anonymous letter but president Trump was
still taking a flamethrower to the
anonymous sources in Bob Woodward's book
today tweeting why should anyone trust
you general mattis general Kelley said
it's not true and comparing Woodward to
a Dem operative prior to the midterms
he was caught cold Woodward on The Today
show this morning beg to differ saying
don't believe the denials believe me
they are not telling the truth I've
never seen a instance when the president
is so detached from the reality of
what's going on despite the terse
back-and-forth president Trump and Bob
Woodward did find some common ground on
that anonymous New York Times op-ed
Woodward criticizing it as being quote
too vague and does not meet the
standards of the building blocks of
journalism
Brett John Roberts live on the North
Lawn John thang